it might seem a curiosity that new labor
was born in Edgefield instead of some
trendy London suburb it was here in this
collection of County Durham X pit mining
villages the Tony Blair the public
school boy found his political feat that
he did was down in no small part to John
Burton local P and history teacher labor
stalwart the five decades standing and
longtime electoral agent and mentor to
the former prime minister this is a
level of this was on a night and this
was lit up came imagine after an
election and the world's press were here
which is absolutely magical
there were great times and everybody was
happy and everybody was enjoying
themselves
George Bush landed in the field over
over the road there oh yeah
and there was two helicopters cuz you
don't never know which one is on oh oh
yeah oh yes that's a bit like me in the
lorry as always a second lorry just us
driving around haha this is my rubella
coming up on so this is my rubella big
one his mother died bless him when he
was quite young you know and so I think
my wife became quite a sort of mother
figure in syria's yes I'm sure you
probably won't broadcast this but I'll
tell you it and then hasn't been
broadcast was that when she was used she
died five years ago with cancer and he
was in he he was in Jerusalem and he
phoned up he said I know Lilly's very
poorly John I'll come next week to see
her so I said I'm sorry Johnny I don't
think she'll be here next week I said
I'm afraid she she's really quite here
that was it eight o'clock on the Monday
night nine o'clock on the choose deer
he'd hired a chartered a plane from
Jerusalem to Newcastle taxi down he had
her in his arms at nine o'clock in the
morning says a lot of other mind isn't
it some people say that the New Labour
wasn't very interested in the working
class they're interested in the middle
class they wanted to kind of move the
party away from its class foundations
and that's why so many Labour voters
decided to leave the well that's not
true I mean he's it was the minimum wage
was that working class was the right to
join a trade union did the things that
they did a working family tax credit she
would start she'll start was an amazing
thing for the working class this was
something to build on and you never was
something to build on so it could go
backwards to oblivion
you think highlight is you think that
could be
he depends after this election about
whether Corbin steps down yeah I think
so yeah
and if he doesn't I think in your party
all-star
and you'd support that I would have to
some are wondering whether the strange
death of Labor England is upon us
despite the polls John Burton thinks
labour will cling on in this
constituency should it not in this of
all places than that death must surely
have come in 1997 won't just be the
greatest labor victory but its last
Lewis got all Sky News said she